une avalanche de plaintes contre une
arnaque aux faux chèques de banque
les victimes sont des internautes qui
proposait des objets ou des véhicules à
vendre sur des sites internet
d'après l'association française des
usagers des banques l'escroquerie
pourrait toucher des milliers de
personnes explications christophe
widemann olivier théron une victime
parmi des centaines d'autres pour alain
buzz est la mésaventure commence sur
internet en octobre 2004 il met sa moto
en vente sur un site de petites annonces
comme celui ci assez rapidement et un
acheteur qui se présente être de
nationalité américaine qui m'a contacté
et m'a demandé les fondamentaux
description kilométrage est normal pour
une annonce au début j'y croyais pas
trop bons américains je me suis dit ça
pouvait le faire le 1er décembre j'ai
donc reçu un chèque de 7000 euros chèque
d'une banque irlandaise laïb et 3500
euros c'est le prix de la moto plus 3500
euros de frais de transport et c'est là
le coeur de l'escroquerie alain buzz et
dépose le chèque à son agence
la somme est crédité sur son compte il
peut donc retiré 3500 euros qu'il envoie
1 transporte situé au nigeria problème
ce transporteur n'existe pas et le
chèque est un faux quand la banque s'en
aperçoit il est trop tard
les 7000 euros sont retirés du compte
alain buzz et a donc perdu les 3500
euros de frais de transport qui ont
atterri dans les poches de l'escroc en
france au moins 250 personnes ont déjà
été victimes de la même arnaque
il convient donc d'être prudent chaque
fois que vous recevez plus d'argent
qu'il n'est convenu
quel que soit le motif invoqué est qu'on
vous demande de renvoyer la différence
sous forme d'un mandat western union
vous devez bloqués ne pas faire la
transaction
certaines victimes pourraient se
retourner contre leurs banques qui ont
crédité de faux chèques comme celui ci
avant d'annuler l'opération